[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hellwig guten abend und
willkommen in einen norbert lehmann ist
auch wieder dabei für den sport guten
abend die regierung scholz verliert ihre
erste ministerin
ein erzwungener rücktritt
familienministerin spiegel muss ihren
hut nehmen weil fehler in der
vergangenheit sie einholen
ein umstrittenes treffen österreichs
kanzler ne hammer ist der erste eu
politiker seit kriegsbeginn der
russlands präsident putin persönlich zum
frieden bringt
und corona testzentren unter verdacht
während die meisten ordnungsgemäß
abrechnen gibt es bundesweit bereits
mehr als 600 verfahren wegen betrugs
ihr umgang mit der flutkatastrophe wurde
ihr zum verhängnis da half auch keine
entschuldigung mehr anne spiegel ist als
bundesfamilienministerin
zurückgetreten das ende einer steilen
politischen karriere
im dezember wurde die grüne als eine der
jüngsten ministerin im kabinett
vereidigt zuvor war die vierfache mutter
im rheinland pfalz umweltministerin
während der flutkatastrophe
gestern abend noch versuchte die 41
jährige mit einem emotionalen auftritt
zu erklären warum sie kurz nach der flut
lange urlaub machte mathis feldhoff
berichtet
es ist ein irritierender auftritt am
gestrigen abend mit einer letzten
stellungnahme versucht
familienministerin spiegel ihre
politische karriere zu retten 18 stunden
später tritt sie mit einer kurzen
schriftlichen erklärung zurück aufgrund
des politischen drucks wie sie schreibt
kurz nach der verheerenden flut im
aartal bei der sie noch als
rheinland-pfälzische umweltministerin
verantwortung trägt war sie in einen
vierwöchigen urlaub gefahren es war ein
fehler dass wir
auch so langen urlaub gefahren sind und
dass wir in urlaub gefahren sind
und ich spitze
für diesen fehler
um entschuldigung zutiefst persönlich
ist ihr auftritt sie macht
gesundheitliche probleme ihres mannes
und belastungen der familie öffentlich
die solidarität der grünen parteispitze
bleibt dennoch auffällig passiv was die
pressekonferenz von einem spiegel angeht
so würde ich für möchte ich kann für
mich sagen dass sie unter die haut
gegangen ist das glaube ich ging also
dies gesehen haben mit dem heutigen tag
ist für sie nicht nur politisch sondern
auch persönlich
einen weg beschritten worden der glaube
ich deutlich macht wie brutal politik
sein kann gerade aus der grünen partei
heraus hatte es massiven druck auf
spiegel gegeben dem gibt sie jetzt nach
der
schritt jetzt nun zurück zu treten ist
bei aller
großen herzen und so schwierig diese
entscheidung auch war richtig wir danken
ihr sehr für diese entscheidung dafür
dass die verantwortung genommen hat es
zeichnet sich das bild einer ministerin
die an ihre persönlichen grenzen
gestoßen war auch die behauptung sie
habe während ihres urlaubs online an
kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen muss sie
korrigieren
ich habe nicht aus meinem urlaub heraus
an den kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen
aber ich möchte betonen dass sich die
ganze zeit erreichbar bei der
bundeskanzler nimmt den rücktritt an die
grünen wollen schnell einen vorschlag
für die nachfolge machen
theo koll in berlin man fragt sich jetzt
warum eine spiegeln sich und ihrer
familie diesen auftritt gestern nicht
erspart hat
also die einzig schlüssige annahme
scheint mir zu sein dass frau spiegel
versucht hat mit diesen privaten
informationen und der geschilderten
familiär notlage ihren politischen kopf
und jahr zu retten ja privatleben sollte
ganz offensichtlich als entschuldigung
für ihr politisches fehlverhalten nähe
halten den
beruflichen preis zahlt sie jetzt
dennoch den privaten hat sie zusätzlich
ihrer familie aufgebürdet indem sie
extrem vertrauliche details über einen
schlaganfall und über corona
folgeschäden vor der nation öffentlich
gemacht hat das muss dem ganzen eine
weitgehende mentale überforderung zu
grunde liegen frau spiegel hat
offensichtlich nicht erkannt dass
angesichts des unendlichen leid der
menschen im aartal die persönliche
situation der zuständigen ministerin
nicht als entschuldigung dienen kann
was bedeutet dieser rücktritt es für die
grünen und für die regierung scheut
und für die ampel regierung ist es vier
monate nach antritt ein politischer
gesichtsverlust neben dem rücktritt von
frau spiegel gelten ja mittlerweile auch
zwei weitere kabinettsmitglieder
lambrecht und lauterbach als angezählte
kandidaten und die grünen stellt der
rücktritt einer frau vom linken flügel
der partei vor ein schier unlösbares
problem einerseits müsste um auch die
geschlechter balance zu halten wieder
eine linke frau in die regierung auf
steigen andererseits soll anton
hofreiter das versprechen in der tasche
haben der erste nachrücker zu sein
sollte ein grüner platz im kabinett frei
werden aber vielleicht entscheidet auch
einfach qualifikation
der chor nach berlin
fragen rund um spiegels amtsverzicht
beantworten wir online und in unserer
zdf heute app dort gibt es eine
zusammenfassung der ereignisse von den
vorwürfen bis zu ihrem rücktritt
zum krieg in der ukraine die eu plant
weitere sanktionen gegen russland über
ein öl-embargo berieten heute die
außenminister es ging aber auch um die
lieferung schwerer waffen an kiew bundes
außenministerin baerbock ist dafür aus
luxemburg anne gellinek
immer mehr bilder der zerstörung kommen
aus den ortschaften rund um kiew die von
der russischen armee geräumt wurden in
badia westlich der ukrainischen
hauptstadt klafft eine gigantische lücke
in ein im blog unterdessen melden die
prorussischen separatisten dass sie
einen teil der hafenstadt mario pohl
unter ihre kontrolle gebracht hätten die
stadt scheint fast völlig verwüstet
solche bilder und die mutmasslicher
kriegsverbrechen an zivilisten haben ein
umdenken in europa beim thema
waffenlieferungen bewirkt die deutsche
aussenministerin ist nun dafür die
ukraine braucht weiteres militärisches
material vor allen dingen auch schwere
waffen und jetzt ist keine zeit für
ausreden sondern jetzt ist zeit für
kreativität und pragmatismus details
nannte bock nicht aber offenbar geht es
um solche veralteten und von der
bundeswehr bereits ausgemusterten
kampfpanzer vom typ leopard 1 sie
müssten allerdings zunächst noch
überprüft und gewartet werden auch die
lieferung von marder schützenpanzern und
panzerhaubitzen steht im raum der
ukrainische präsident zealand ski hatte
in seiner nächtlichen rede den
kurswechsel der deutschen regierung
bereits begrüßt und gleichzeitig
schärfere sanktionen gefordert wie zum
beispiel ein embargo gegen russisches öl
darüber allerdings streitet europa noch
die osteuropäer sind dafür deutschland
und einige andere dagegen für
diskussionsstoff sorgt auch die reise
des österreichischen kanzlers zugleich
die mehr putin nach moskau es ist der
erste besuch eines europäischen
regierungschefs seit kriegsbeginn jede
stimme die den bildenden putin
verdeutlicht wie die realität sich
außerhalb der mauern des kremls wirklich
darstellt ist keine verlorene stimme
ich persönlich glaube nicht dass wir mit
ihm sprechen sollten es sei denn über
seine strafrechtliche verantwortung für
diesen krieg
europa versucht eine doppelstrategie
dialog mit un sanktionen gegen russland
und gleichzeitig waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine
axel sturm steht vor der residenz des
österreichischen botschafters in moskau
wo gerade der kanzler auftrat axel was
hat dieses treffen gebracht es sollte er
auf keinen fall putin eine bühne bieten
nein das war schon ein kernanliegen
keine große diplomatische bühne keine
bilder für die welt kein anzeichen
darauf hin dass man sich ernährt an den
russischen staatspräsidenten und dennoch
war es dem österreichischen
bundeskanzler offenbar doch ein
dringliches anliegen mit ihm zu sprechen
das hat er getan er hat vor wenigen
minuten erklärt er sei nicht sonderlich
optimistisch nach den gesprächen seine
kernaussage sei gewesen dass er putin
dazu aufgefordert habe ein ende der wie
sie heißt so genannten militärischen
spezialoperation herbeizuführen ob das
gelingt steht in den sternen vom kreml
gibt es bislang noch kein statement
axel sturm live aus moskau dankeschön
ja trotz dialog und druck vor allem im
osten der ukraine gehen die kämpfe
weiter neben mario pohl besonders unter
beschuss ist fraglich am nachmittag
wurde dort ein wohnviertel angegriffen
fünf menschen sollen getötet worden sein
auch ein kind trotz der gefahr sind in
kharkiv unermüdlich helfer im einsatz
und journalisten wie arndt ginzel der
sie begleitet hatte
das rote kreuz in kharkiv die helfer
bereiten einen einsatz vor sie verpacken
windeln hygieneartikel medikamente für
die menschen in den umkämpften gebieten
es war geplant dass wir heute in rackith
hilfe leisten und auch menschen
evakuieren wir haben dafür drei autos
vorbereitet und dann mussten wir aber
alles abblasen weil dort gekämpft wird
und weil dort panzer stehen
wie gefährlich die fahrten durch aktiv
sind sehen wir an den krankenwagen
selbst das rote kreuz gerät hier unter
beschuss dann steigt plötzlich rauch auf
über der stadt in einem wohnviertel in
der nähe ist eine rakete eingeschlagen
dieses einfamilienhaus ist völlig
zerstört
eine straße weiter noch ein einschlag
der russische angriff hat menschenleben
gekostet
mein mann wurde getötet er saß auf einer
bank dann ist das geschoss eingeschlagen
ich weiß nicht was es war
morgen wollten wir nach polen ausreisen
und das ist jetzt daraus geworden
ein paar meter weiter von dem haus vor
dem noch der verstorbene zivilist liegt
finden wir eine rakete die jetzt gerade
eben hier eingeschlagen und hat
todesopfer gefordert mehrere menschen
sind verletzt die angriffe auf fragt eve
nehmen zu und fordern immer mehr zivile
opfer
nach frankreich weil dort gestern kein
kandidat für das präsidentenamt die
absolute mehrheit bekam geht es in zwei
wochen in die stichwahl und die ist auch
für europa entscheidend
amtsinhaber makro holte im ersten
durchgang die meisten stimmen
27,8 prozent seine gegnerin am sonntag
in zwei wochen die rechtspopulistin
marine le pen kommt auf 23,2 prozent nur
knapp geschlagen der linkspopulist
jean-luc melo schon mit 22 aus paris
thomas walde
nach dem wahlkampf ist vor dem wahlkampf
immer nur nach rom besucht heute den er
eine arbeiter gegend und demonstriert
stunden lang die bürgernähe die er
bisher vermissen ließ
viele franzosen wollen ja gerne für sie
im zweiten wahlgang stimmen aber sie
müssen ihnen sicherheit geben herr
präsident es tut mir leid ich stimme
ihnen ja zu man darf aber keine
sicherheit vorgaukeln mit falschen
versprechungen es braucht ernsthafte
bemühungen
max gegnerin in der stichwahl marine le
pen will die unzufriedenen hinter sich
versammeln ihr hauptthema bleibt die
kaufkraft
die inflation liegt nicht hinter uns
sondern vor und sie ist eine last die
die regierung nicht sehen will
viel wird davon abhängen wie seine
anhänger sich entscheiden der linke jörg
müller chance verpasste knapp den einzug
in die stichwahl
und nun
keine einzige stimme für madame le pen
ruft indessen nicht dazu auf nun makro
zu wählen und bei seinen anhängern sind
lippen und makro verhasst
die ehemals regierenden parteien der
republik und der sozialisten landeten
unter fünf prozent und kämpfen um das
politische überleben eine
stichwahl wie 2017 also und doch ist
frankreichs politische landschaft
radikal verändert das nationalistische
lager stärker als je zuvor und der
wahlkampf ist noch nicht vorbei
die europäische union beendet vorerst
ihre militärische ausbildungsmission im
westafrikanischen mali das kündigte der
eu außenbeauftragte borel an zuletzt
trainierten unter anderem rund 300
deutsche soldaten malische armee
angehörige im kampf gegen terrorgruppen
in mali hatte das militär die macht
übernommen und zuletzt auch russische
söldner engagiert
immer wieder ist die hessische polizei
im fokus der justiz wegen beamten die in
chat gruppen rechtsextreme bilder und
videos austauschen
erst vor wenigen tagen ist eine in
darmstadt aufgeflogen von 2014 bis 2018
gab es eine solche gruppe auch bei der
frankfurter polizei heute erhob die
staatsanwaltschaft anklage fünf beamten
wird vorgeworfen in einem chat
rechtsextremistische und
menschenverachtende inhalte geteilt zu
haben
jetzt zur corona pandemie da sinkt die
bundesweite sieben tage incident zweiter
und liegt nun bei
1080 dem robert koch institut wurden 30
1789 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages
gemeldet 10 1340 weniger als vergangenen
montag
manche bereichern sich an dieser
pandemie so gibt es mittlerweile an
jeder ecke testzentren aber nicht alle
sind seriös mehr als
640 verfahren wegen betrugs gibt es
bundesweit gegen solche zentren es geht
um falsche ab jungen aber auch um
auffallend geringe corona trefferquoten
der schaden soll im hohen zweistelligen
millionenbereich liegen aus stuttgart
berichten petra otto und jan frederik
fischer
einmal abstreichen mehrfach abrechnen
wohl keine seltenheit und für die täter
lukrativ bei 11 eur 50 protest vom staat
die staatsanwaltschaften ermitteln
bundesweit mindestens
642 verfahren wegen mutmaßlichen
abrechnungsbetrugs auch das
landeskriminalamt baden württemberg hat
alle hände voll zu tun wieso haben wir
festgestellt mehrere hundert solcher
verfahren die auch polizeilichen
bearbeitung sind die schadenshöhe können
derzeit noch nicht genau beziffern die
bewegen sich aber im oberen
millionenbereich hinweise auf kriminelle
strukturen organisierte kriminalität
haben wir derzeit nicht schwer
nachzuweisen wo betrogen wird die
dunkelziffer hoch dazu kommen oft auch
schlechte hygiene standards
unvollständige unterlagen in baden
württemberg haben sie kontrolliert und
gravierende mängel festgestellt bei mehr
als der hälfte der schnelltest zentren
saubere teststationen geraten da unter
generalverdacht bei so vielen schwarzen
schafen wozu braucht es überhaupt an
jeder ecke an schnelltests zentrum jetzt
wo die maßnahmen gelockert sind und kaum
noch nachweise verlangt werden uns
glaube ich kann man auf die sukzessive
verzichten es sollten symptomatische
menschen getestet werden dann aber
vernünftig mit einem pcr test und ich
glaube von diesen doch in der qualität
sehr unterschiedlichen bürger test an
jeder ecke können wir uns jetzt langsam
verabschieden kostenlose bürger tests
damit soll wohl auch schon ende mai
schluss sein die verfahren gegen
abrechnungsbetrug die laufen noch lange
und jetzt fußball-champions-league
norbert beginnt morgen für die bayern um
die woche beim viertelfinal rückspiel
gegen villarreal
letzte woche hatte der fcb ja in spanien
0 1 verloren und war damit sogar noch
gut bedient jetzt brauchen die bayern
also im rückspiel daheim einen klaren
sieg es ist die entscheidende phase der
saison und nagels manns nerven sind
sichtlich angespannt die vorstellung
gegen augsburg das andere als eine
geglückte generalprobe wir haben
überhaupt keine führungskrise wir
kommunizieren viel wir überlegen uns
jedes mal was können wir besser machen
er im viertelfinal-hinspiel steckte der
kapitän mit fehlern wie diesem seine
mitspieler an das einzig gute am laut
trainer nagelsmann schlechtesten spiel
seit langem es ging nur 0 zu 1 verloren
nun sollen die erfahrenen wie müller
oder neuer vorangehen die intensität
muss deutlich hochgeschraubt werden es
waren die spieler also zwei drei tagen
an alleine ja nicht mal eine lange
offline ist und so eine sehr kurze und
jetzt morgen will ich noch diese
silbernen schnalle vorne aufmachen dann
müssen sie laufen hoffentlich dann alle
in eine richtung und mit größeren
schritten damit das halbfinale noch
erreicht werden kann
morgen gibt es auch spannenden
frauenfußball serbien gegen deutschland
zu sehen bei uns im zdf ab 15 uhr 45 das
dfb team ist heute in belgrad angekommen
und bereitet sich auf das wm quali spiel
vor nach sieben siegen in sieben gruppen
spielen sind die deutschen frauen
natürlich der favorit sollten sie wieder
gewinnen ja dann wäre das ticket für die
weltmeisterschaft vorzeitig gelöst
und im letzten sonntagsspiel hat gestern
abend fußball-bundesligist leipzig seine
erfolgsserie fortgesetzt die beste
rückrundenmannschaft gewannen souverän
gegen hoffenheim mit 3 zu 0 und ist als
tabellenvierter weiter auf champions
league kurs domenico tedesco und leipzig
das passt seit er trainer ist hat der r
b 10 von 15 liga spielen gewonnen oder
auch gegen hoffenheim gelang vieles von
beginn an treffer eins nach freistoß
schon in der fünften minute durch
christopher höpken bleibt sich
torhungrig hat mit 34 treffern die
meisten tore in dieser rückrunde erzielt
marcel halstenberg mit dem 20 der
verteidiger nach elf monaten
verletzungspause zurück in der startelf
das 3 0 von dominik so mosler besiegelte
dann schon kurz vor der pause den sieg
für leipzig gelungene generalprobe vor
dem europa league rückspiel in der
kammer alle
höhepunkte und alle thrones 29 spieltags
wie immer zu sehen bei zdf heute.de und
in der zdf- heute apps eingestellt
glaube das wetter macht freude mit sonne
und wärme wie lange das so bleibt sagt
in gleich aus dem terry marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn im heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter auf dem atlantik hat sich ein
tief festgetackert kann man hier sagen
und schiebt immer wieder seine wolken in
unsere richtung bei uns ist hoher
luftdruck und der wird von diesen wolken
gestört aber das tief lenkt auch warme
luft aus nordafrika zu uns und da ist
sogar saharastaub dabei schauen wir in
die nacht und da wird es im osten
aufklaren stern klar wird es hier seien
mit dem hohen luftdruck sonst sind eher
harmlose wolken unterwegs meist hohe
wolken da fällt kein regen heraus und
die temperaturen sinken auf minus vier
grad im osten deutschlands minus ein
grad im südosten und 8 grad am
niederrhein morgen dann vor allem im
süden viel sonne richtungen bayern und
sonst im südwesten ebenfalls hier kann
auch saharastaub dabei sein ansonsten
sind die worte im norden etwas kompakter
insgesamt weiterhin trockenes wetter bei
höchsten temperaturen von 11 bis 15 grad
im nordosten hier sahen kühlsten aber
schauen sie mal nach südwesten bis 23
grad geht es da hoch temperaturen im
westen meist um die 20 grad marke
die kommenden tage es wird wärmer
mittwoch bis 24 grad aber im nord westen
eine kaltfront mit schauern und
gewittern ein schöner abend